a posthumous birth is when a baby is
born after the death of his or her
parent it's something that's almost sure
to have psychological implications for
both the child and the surviving parent
as we've seen before in Stephen King's
carry in the strained relationship
between Terry and her mother another
example is a Nightmare on Elm Street 5
with Alice and her son Jacob but there
is perhaps no darker an example of the
effects of a posthumous birth than in
the 2014 horror film The babadook the
protagonist a mother named Emilia loses
her husband in a car wreck just before
giving birth to her son Samuel but
something else is born that day a
monster that would become known as the
babadook to learn about the origins of
this icon of modern horror and the part
of the ending that nobody's talking
about stick around to the end of this
video this video is sponsored by Factor
life is not always as it seems it can be
a wondrous thing but it can also be very
treacherous welcome to Horror history if
you're watching this video this Horror
history lesson then you probably already
know what the babadook represents so
let's just cut the and Skip to My
conclusion at the end of the video where
I tell you that the babadook represents
the grief of the struggling mother
Amelia I think everyone already kind of
knows that about this movie it's not
going to be a groundbreaking Revelation
when I say that at the end of the video
nobody's mind is going to be blown oh my
God I never looked at it like that I'm
gonna subscribe to this guy nah what I'm
more interested for this video is how
the babadook is the embodiment of grief
from the way he behaves to his
appearance to the secret lore that you
can only get if you have the physical
copy of the Mr babadook book The Duck
book the movie is actually an adaptation
of writer director Jennifer Kent's 2005
short film a monster it similarly
features a single mom of a child named
Samuel who is obsessed with fighting
monsters the mother eventually starts
seeing the horror for herself in a 2014
interview with the cut Jennifer Kent
explained that this character was
inspired by a friend of hers who was a
single mother whose son was traumatized
by a monster figure he thought he saw
everywhere in the house causing Jennifer
to imagine what would happen if the
monster was real on some level the
monster in the original short film is
not named but the one in the babadook is
in case you haven't figured that out
while speaking to the dissolve Kent said
she was staying with a Serbian writer
and asked him what Serbian for Boogeyman
he said babaroga but that didn't sound
quite right to her so she changed it to
babadook and it just felt right but I
think it sounds [__] stupid as we
know the babadook represents grief and
grief is often experienced in five
stages denial anger bargaining
depression and acceptance this is known
as the Kubla Ross model named after the
Swiss psychiatrist Elizabeth Kubler-Ross
who identified it when I first set out
to make this video I assumed that each
stage would present itself
chronologically but what I noticed was
that Emilia would often go backwards and
demonstrate symptoms of the first four
stages multiple times so I did some more
reading and found out that Kubler-Ross
never actually intended the stages to be
linear people can experience these
aspects of grief at different times and
they don't happen in one particular
order but with that in mind the first
stage to present itself in the movie is
deny so to understand the Journey of the
babadook we're going to take it back to
stage one
foreign
it All Began seven years before the
events of the film when Amelia's husband
Oscar was killed while driving her to
the hospital to give birth instead of
facing her trauma Amelia avoids it she
literally locks all of his stuff up in
the basement and forbids her son from
going inside a representation of how
she's locking away her grief and
refusing to face it she avoids talking
about it and even gets upset when
friends or family members broach the
subject at all this essentially gives
birth to the babadook the babadook
metaphorically grows inside her the
longer she tries to deny her trauma but
after years of doing this it grows too
large for her to keep in and even Samuel
takes note of it in both monster and the
babadook Samuel becomes obsessed with
killing the monster with the former
inventing homemade Contraptions to fight
back against it like a dart gun and a
catapult backpack both versions are
obsessed with protecting their mother
from the threat it's interesting how the
absence of a parent causes Sam to want
to take on this man of the house kind of
role the short film version of the
monster is similar in appearance to the
babadook with one key difference the
babadook wears a top hat in a cape much
like Thurston the great magician who
Samuel sees as an idol Sam is an
aspiring magician himself often dressing
up like his hero perhaps the closest
thing that the boy has to a father
figure in his life it's likely no
mistake that the babadook takes on a
similar form since Emilia's grief is
centered around the loss of a man in the
house a DVD of an Illusionist is no
proper replacement for a dad every year
around the time of Samuel's birthday
Emilia's anxiety gets worse in
Psychology this is known as the
anniversary effect this article from the
American Psychological Association lists
a few healthy coping strats like
recognizing your feelings finding
healthy Outlets remembering and
celebrating the lives of loved ones and
using your support system but since
Emilia is still in denial she doesn't do
any of these except for the last one
each year they do a joint birthday party
for Samuel and his cousin Ruby so that
Amelia doesn't have to celebrate on the
actual day of the Oscar's death a couple
weeks before Samuel's seventh birthday
those feelings rise up again but Ruby no
longer wants to do a joint birthday
party this essentially eliminates
Amelia's last line of defense from
having to face her trauma and as a
result the babadook manifests in the
real world for the first time in the
form of a book called Mr babadook when
Samuel chooses it as a bedtime story
Emilia doesn't know what it is or where
it came from if it's in a word or it's
in a look you can't get rid of the
babadook the tax skills aren't to say if
you're a really clever one and you know
what it is to see then you can make
friends with a special one a friend of
you and me his name is Mr babadook
and this is his book this is telling us
that it takes a special person or a
person with a lot of resilience to learn
to live with the grief inside of them
which is what Amelia has to do in this
movie it goes on to explain that the
babadook can be identified by a rumbling
sound and three sharp knocks followed by
the croaking of its name the book also
hints at a much more terrifying true
form of the babadook see him in your
room at night and you won't sleep awake
I'll soon take off my funny disguise
take heat of what you've read and once
you see what's underneath you're going
to wish you were dead Samuel is
terrified causing Amelia to put the book
Away high on top of a dresser much like
how she puts her difficult to face
feelings out of sight and mind after
this Samuel's Behavior continues to
worsen at first it appears to be Sam's
Disobedience that stresses out his mom
but it would soon become apparent that
his behavior is actually a result of
Amelia's inability to manage her grief
which has an effect on her parenting
when he gets in trouble at school she
insists that she'll talk to him but we
never see that happen and she continues
to avoid conflict A co-worker offers to
cover for her at work and instead of
picking up her son she takes some time
to herself before going back to him when
she finds picks him up from her sister's
house she finds that he scared the crap
out of Ruby with his antics
instead of talking to this bloody
babadook thing all day just talking to
the air there's a confrontation when
Samuel insists that the babadook is real
and defiantly spikes a firecracker on
the ground distracted with her own
wallowing she's completely lost control
of her own son where did you get those
firecrackers
that's the end of the internet okay bye
the ornery Behavior continues and in her
frustration Amelia begins to experience
the second stage of grief anger
[Music]
it is August which means Halloween is
coming up which means I have been so
busy I literally do not know what I
would do if I didn't have Factor right
now so factor is the meal delivery
service owned by hellofresh another
favorite of mine but factor is perfect
for me right now because start to finish
it is ready in two minutes you just pop
these containers in the microwave and
it's ready to eat but even though they
come in containers it's not like a TV
dinner type of deal it's real dietitian
approved food and Factor meals are
guaranteed fresh and never Frozen they
offer 34 plus weekly flavor-packed
options and you can level up even
further with factors Gourmet plus
options prepared to Perfection by chefs
these are the perfect way to treat
yourself to upscale meals so they sent
me one of these and I don't know what
the secret is but the steak doesn't get
dry or tough like when you bring home
leftovers from a restaurant it's just
perfection I've gotta go I'm kind of too
busy to do this ad right now but head to
factor75.com or click the link below and
use code cz50 to get 50 off your first
Factor box that's code cz50 to get 50 I
have so much to do I'm leaving
foreign
's rage is initially sparked when she
catches her son with the key to the
basement where all of Oscar's old things
are kept as she tries to put things back
in order she's startled by his old hat
and Blazer on the coat rack this shows
that the appearance of the babadook
isn't just inspired by the magician but
that Oscar had a similar sense of style
and the creature is filling the void of
his absence Samuel's apparent
transgressions begin to pile up Amelia
finds glass in her soup finds the
picture of her and Oscar vandalized with
her eyes and mouth made to look kind of
like the babadook and he even seems to
get physically aggressive when she tries
to take away his homemade monster
fighting weapons
do you wanna die fighting words from
someone who is literally three and a
half feet tall but kind of based the
next night he sees his wardrobe open on
its own we don't find out what happens
but there's a huge thud Samuel screams
and his mom finds him hyperventilating
under the bed repeatedly saying don't
let it in while it appears that he's
worried about the monster getting into
the house as warned in the storybook on
a subtextual level he's telling her not
to let her Dark Side get in and take
hold of her something that has obviously
happened before still not having
accepted the existence of the babadook
Emilia tries to rip up the book and
throw it away which is about as useful
as putting Chucky in the trash the
horror always comes back that night she
hears the three knocks as specified in
the book
[Music]
the toll that the babadook is taking on
her becomes apparent the next day at
Ruby's birthday party of all of the moms
at the party she's the only one not
wearing makeup and while I don't find
makeup to be necessary I think the
implication is that she's the only one
who didn't have time to do it again we
see her anger slip out in unintended
ways when one of the women says that
she's been too busy to go to the gym
because of her husband's business
I don't even have time to go to the gym
anymore it's ridiculous that's a real
tragedy not having time to go to the gym
anymore how do you cope
he must have so much to talk about with
those poor disadvantaged women
wait where have I seen this before
yep that's the one her Outburst makes it
seem as though Amelia probably hasn't
had the opportunity to exercise in a
long time which is also probably
connected to her escalating grief
symptoms this meta-analysis found that
exercise during bereavement can have a
positive effect on psychological health
and plus I think we all know that it's
common sense that you feel better when
you exercise meanwhile Ruby bullies
Samuel for not having a dad antagonizing
him by saying that his dad isn't around
because he doesn't want it this causes
Sam to snap no one wants you
welcome to the kill count
I'm so immature
during the Tantrum on the car ride home
Sam starts screaming at an unseen entity
telling it to get out it makes sense
that he would be able to see the
babadook before her because she has yet
to accept that she's the problem Sam
starts convulsing in the back seat which
leads to an emergency doctor's visit
where it's concluded that he experienced
a federal convulsion basically
overheating of the brain the doctor is
concerned about his anxiety level but
sees the invention of a monster to be a
perfectly normal thing for a child to
imagine however we know that the monster
is a metaphor for Amelia's grief so it's
really her mental issues that are
causing harm and distress to her own son
a pretty sad situation the doctor
reluctantly supplies her with some
sedatives to help Sam sleep at night
just until they can get an appointment
with the psychiatrist this helps her get
a much needed rest until the next
morning when she hears the familiar
three knocks on her door and looks down
to discover the Mr babadook book she had
discarded with all of the pages pasted
back together it's as the book
forewarned you can't get rid of the
babadook this time when she flips
through it there are new pages added the
ant I'll wager with you I'll make you a
bat the more you deny the stronger I get
the next page shows the babadook
terrorizing her in the night you start
to change when I get in the babadook
rowing right under your skin Oh come
come see what's underneath this again
teases at the idea that what we've seen
is not the babadook's true form the
language seems to playfully reference
the magician again the O come come see
kind of reminds me of a sort of come on
come all it's almost time to start the
show I should have done that at the
beginning of this episode I should do
that in all my videos come on come all
to another episode of Horror history all
I need is like the nice Justin Wang
mustache in 2014 a limited number of
these books were merchandised the author
is Jennifer Kent which kind of suggests
to me that the content of this book is
Canon the movie does show some of these
additional pages but the full context is
lost in the cut there's just no way
you're off the hook if you're all grown
up and you read this book and you snub
your nose with a civilized look you'll
appeal even more to the big baba deck
the woman in the picture here appears to
be Amelia and this scene of the babadook
frightening her from above would
eventually actually come to happen in
the movie the next page confirms what we
already kind of figured out about the
monster feeding off of her denial to
gain strength then you'll be my puppets
my plaything my pets I'll make you do
things you'll be sure to regret to me
this is about the ability for her mental
illness to take over her life and it
basically ruin things for her which
manifests in the babadook as the power
to possess and Puppeteer the victim the
following Pages show her choking the dog
then her son before offing herself there
are more pages in the physical book that
line up with more of Amelia's story but
I'll come back to that in a little bit
it's at this point that Amelia tries
torching the book but not long after she
receives an ominous phone call uttering
the familiar words
she even tries going to the police but
that's not really helpful seeing as how
she just burned the only evidence and
she ends up getting further spooked by
this image of a hat and claws on the
coat rack at the police station at home
there are more signs that her sanity is
starting to slip the dog pugsy barks at
her and seems to be afraid of her now
the house is a mess and she discovers a
cockroach infestation behind the fridge
and as all these problems are piling up
she's visited by state officials about
the well-being of her son and they see
that he's basically mellowed out on
sleep medication for the first time she
sees the babadook with her own eyes
momentarily standing in her neighbor's
house this not only serves to make
Amelia question her own sanity but it
shows that all of her problems are
connected her mental state caused her to
neglect cleaning the house which led to
the appearance of the Cockroaches the
neighbor's name is Mrs roach an elderly
woman with Parkinson's disease and the
babadook has cockroach-like qualities it
emits this hissing sound and in one
dream it can be seen scuttling across
the ceiling like a roach the idea is
that Emilia cannot compartmentalize her
grief if she doesn't address it it's
going to affect all aspects of her life
after this dream she wakes up Samuel and
takes him downstairs clearly starting to
fear the babadook is a real threat for
the first time she finds herself
watching a strange old film on TV this
is a real silent film from 1900 calls it
the magic book in which this magician
brings the illustrations in this magic
book to life it was directed by French
director George melier who started his
career as a stage magician before
getting involved in film The version
that Emilia watches however is altered
and she sees the babadook appear in that
book and other old Mellie movie scenes
which keeps her awake all night leaving
her sick and exhausted the next morning
and setting her up for stage 4
depression
[Music]
thank you
depression is characterized by loss of
motivation loss of interest and
inability to feel pleasure Amelia climbs
into bed and ignores her
responsibilities as a mother even when
Samuel tells her that he feels sick from
the sleeping pills and needs food she
sees his cries for help as an annoyance
and lashes out at him with anger and
after realizing what she's done finds
him in a fetal position on the floor She
attempts to make up for it by taking him
to his favorite restaurant but the booth
next to theirs is celebrating a birthday
a looming reminder about Sam's own
birthday and the anniversary of Oscar's
death she decides to take him for a long
drive afterwards but suddenly sees
roaches in her lap and the image of the
babadook tailing their car this causes
her to swerve and crash the vehicle and
in a panic runs from the scene of the
incident she's spiraling further and
further out of control when she gets
home she plunges back into her
depression clinging to the things that
comfort her she sits in the warm bathtub
in her clothes not doing anything and
goes to sleep with Oscar's Old Violin
even Sam begins to fear her and attempts
to call Mrs roach to see if he can stay
over there instead but when she catches
him she cuts the phone line to prevent
him from embarrassing her any further
you know Amelia usually the bad guys
that want to do that but go ahead knock
yourself out actually it kind of tracks
considering that the babadook is just a
manifestation of her grief in a way she
is the bad guy of this story and the
conflict is the internal struggle she's
having against herself her role is a lot
like Jack Torrance from The Shining both
characters started with good intentions
but are consumed by the reflections to
become the villain and it wouldn't be
long before the monster's promise of
making her his puppet would become a
reality she still insists that the
babadook isn't real another clear-cut
example of her denial and she makes a
huge scene out of closing and locking
all the windows the cycle of treating
Sam with cruelty to pampering him
continues through the night until she's
lured out of the living room by the
illusion of her son asleep walking into
the basement when she arrives there
she's shocked to see her late husband
Oscar
bargaining is described as the defense
mechanism you go through to fight
against the feeling of helplessness
during a loss it's essentially the
series of what-if scenarios you may go
through in your head to try to cope with
that which you cannot control maybe
you've experienced this to some degree
if I hadn't said those things maybe we
wouldn't have broken up or if I worked
longer hours they wouldn't have let me
go for Emilia the bargaining stage
happens in a very direct way with her
coming face to face with her deceased
loved one and him literally making her
an offer you can be together
you just need to bring me the boy be
part of her subconscious responsible for
seeing Oscar still feels that if they
never had a child she never would have
lost her husband but when she refuses to
offer up her son he recedes into the
darkness later emerging from the kitchen
with the insectile hiss scaring her away
to the bedroom wherever she goes she's
unable to avoid her trauma and it comes
down through the chimney where it
finally gets her and takes over her body
the book warned that it would make her
do think she'd regret and that's exactly
what happened the dog comes downstairs
as she's watching a movie and she chases
him down and snaps his neck in the
kitchen she hasn't been a good mom up to
this point but this is by far the most
reprehensible thing she does her anger
goes unchecked and to signify this we
see her pull out her tooth which we'd
seen her grinding throughout the movie
as her anger grew after noticing Samuel
spying from the top of the stairs she
chases after him and he locks himself
away in his room causing her to turn
into something almost demonic as she
climbs the wall trying to kick in the
door and screams let me in the same
phrase used by the babadook in the
children's book speaking of that book
after scaring him with it for the first
time she had to calm him down by reading
him fairy tale and she uses similar
tactics here yeah
a little six years old and you're still
wetting yourself by calling him a little
pig she's calling back to the big bad
wolf story that she read him earlier
funny enough I made the Jack Torrance
comparison earlier and he too used the
big bad wolf to taunt his own victims
Little Pigs let me come in not buy the
hair on your chinny chin chin then I
huff and I'll pass and I'll blow your
house in Samuel throws a firecracker at
her feet to try to escape and she
mockingly sangs
[Music]
another fairy tale reference the chase
would go on for a while longer including
an interruption from a concerned Mrs
roach and it would end with Sam who has
nowhere else to run striking his mom and
knocking her out I guess his fighting
words earlier were not so unwarranted
after all this kid's the real deal when
she awakes she finds herself in one more
fairy tale-like scenario tied down with
rope in the basement like the Giant in
Gulliver's Travels I think the
references to all these fairy tales are
to highlight how the babadook draws upon
elements from fairy tales which often
contain moral lessons and allegorical
Elements which is what we're supposed to
be looking for here as well and it seems
by this point Sam very much understands
the true nature of the babadook because
he says this I know you don't love me
the brother duck won't let you but I
love you Mom and I always will
oh yeah
you have to get it out her hands get
free and the babadook forces her to
strangle her own son but she seems to
get a hold of herself and vomits out a
black substance essentially expelling
the creature's control over her body and
while this is a good first step Sam
reminds her you can't get rid of the
babadook and then he's aerated up the
stairs I still remember seeing this
movie for the first time in 2014 and
rolling my eyes when I saw this I think
this was actually the first time that I
ever coined this as a common phenomena
in horror movies I don't know if I
called it aerating yet I'm not sure if
Yeet had entered the Lexicon at that
point but I definitely had seen The
Conjuring and carry and Insidious 2 the
previous year and I was pretty sick of
seeing characters get pulled out of thin
air in every horror movie and the
babadook was just the one that broke me
because it didn't need to do that there
seems to be a lot of talk about the
babadook being so intelligent and
elevated but really when you break it
down it's the same flickering lights
creepy phone calls possession black
vomit moving furniture and air eating
that was going on in every paranormal
movie at the time I'm not a babadook
hater I like that they're substance of
the movie but don't act like it
reinvented the genre or anything also
this one area is kind of funny
[Music]
I'm so immature as the bed starts
shaking Emilia screams Into the Dark
Void on the other side of the room
asking
for the first time she acknowledges the
creature as something more than a
figment of her son's imagination and in
doing so she acknowledges the problem
growing inside of her and this takes her
too
once more Oscar emerges from the Shadows
this time he begins repeating his lines
from right before the car crash and
Emilia is forced to see and live through
the tragedy all over again but this time
instead of going straight into denial
she gets mad and confronts the monster
festering in the Darkness
yeah don't ever talk to me or my son
again although it seems to have reached
its final form her ferocity seems too
weak in the babadook and it shrinks back
into the darkness leaving only the hat
and jacket which fall to the floor upon
touching these clothing articles the
entity screeches at her scampers down to
the basement and locks itself in and
from this point although she seems to
have overcome the babadook that's far
from the whole story
[Music]
I withheld the rest of the story from
the physical babadook book until now for
probably the same reason that the end of
the book is never shown in the film it
would kind of spoil it you cannot get
rid of me dare to look me in my face try
to put me in my place I will cause you
so much stride but you might just get
out with your life whether adult or
child the best to give me a home put the
welcome mat out with a room of my own
and accept that I'm here and from you I
have grown keep me smaller in size I
might leave you alone I only said might
you can't get rid of the babadook so the
only solution is to learn to live with
it in a healthy way after that final
night we see Amelia attempting to do
just that she explains to the social
workers that they celebrated Sam's
birthday on the actual day for the first
time only now she's being very
transparent about why they never did it
before she can also be seen planting
black roses a universal symbol of
mourning in the backyard over where the
dog is now buried which shows us that
this time she's dealing with the grief
head-on instead of avoiding it like she
did for seven years with Oscar her and
Sam collect a bowl of worms from the spa
and she instructs him to stay inside
while she takes the bowl into the
basement where the babadook is locked up
and seemingly feeds him using the bowl
of worms the short film monster has a
similar ending where the mother
periodically feeds the monster a glass
of milk to keep it satiated so what is
the significance of the switch to worms
as the snack of choice for the babadook
I think it has to do with the journey
that Emilia has gone through to reach
this point during the climax no not that
climax she was so far gone that she
killed her dog and nearly her son if you
look closely the worms are picked right
from above the dog's grave site so she
seems to be using them as a motivation
to keep her grief in check by taking
some time to acknowledge it every now
and then so it doesn't grow and fester
into a monster that she cannot control
Amelia never fully defeats the babadook
but this is a good first step towards
taking some of its power and making it
more manageable the film as a whole
plays as a very lonely isolating
experience because only her and the sun
encounter it if you're not living in
that house it would be difficult to ever
truly understand Jennifer Ken's next
movie The Nightingale also features a
mother who loses her husband and baby at
the beginning of the movie and she sets
out for revenge like the babadook
there's no real catharsis there's only
learning to better deal with the
circumstances at hand Emilia is at the
beginning of a road to Healing a road
that there is no guarantee she'll make
it down but just as Amelia's battle is
not over neither is your viewing session
I've got more Horror history analyzes
lined up in that playlist on the left
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new Horrors every week ring the death
bell for all notifications and I'll see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
foreign